[Music]
five four three two one
what's up everyone welcome to simulation
we have an awesome episode today we are
featuring dr. Alan Stern dr. David
Grinspoon what's up guys oh man well
we're traveling the land and telling
tales of new horizons we have a book
chasing new horizons inside the epic
first mission to Pluto and it tells the
story of how how a mission like new
horizons really happens the stuff you
you don't know but you wonder about and
it's it's quite a tale of many years of
struggle and surprising twists and turns
and heartbreak and ultimate triumph and
that's oh yeah that's that's what we're
doing hell yes this is so important to
tell the story about because your
backgrounds are astrobiology and with
NASA with the New Horizons mission
itself as the danceable investigator as
as people that care so much about what
we live in today and where we came from
and where we're going in the vastness of
the cosmos all these things is is one
and I and we do two here on the show
you are now illustrating exactly what it
takes to be able to plan get it done
leave the rock go and try and explore
and it's really hard yeah there's a lot
of layers to it in this case it started
with people who just had a dream who
wanted there were some unfinished
business
you know NASA explored all the planets
from Mercury all the way to Neptune and
you know Pluto was just sitting out
there as we say they look kind of like a
dare yeah come get me but it was a
mystery world you know it was a dot we
knew a few things about it and it seemed
weird the more we learned about it we
were like this is an unusual place and
as Alan and his team were struggling to
get this mission to happen which was a
crazy series of you know starts and
restarts and cancellations and you know
heartbreak and anyways now as that was
happening all throughout more than a
decade discoveries were made here on
earth that made people realize Pluto was
more interesting because it turns out
it's not just this oddball on the edge
of the solar system out there by itself
it's part of this whole zone of
trillions of objects yeah and a zone
that contains answers to how our solar
system got here so it turns out that
it's the tip of the iceberg of this
fascinating part of the solar system we
didn't even know about when they started
the Kuiper belt Dutch guy that's guy
named Cooper Cooper yes yeah and in
actually Pluto's not that much larger
than the other large rocks or so ever so
let's distinguish rocks from planets
okay
rocks are things are gonna have an eel
shaped like this chair or you or this
building right and there's an you're a
rock but you do rock but but things that
are small have their shape controlled by
the chemical bonds basically their
mechanical strength but every planet
you've ever seen is round because above
a certain mass gravity will shape
objects to be spheres and that's why
when you watch Star Trek you know a
planet when you see one because it's
this big round thing might have little
bumps on it right it might have a
equatorial bulge if it's rotating
quickly in this centripetal force but
you always know when you see it on the
viewfinder right you can recognize it
right away it's it's round and and so
the Kuiper belt has true literally
trillions which is thousands of billions
of small things and about a dozen really
big things above which with weird names
like Makemake
and IRA's and XE on and how maiya and
Pluto Pluto is the first discovered it's
the brightest though and the largest of
that whole population but it turns out
this is the third class of planet in our
solar system we have a little
rocky wins the four Mercury Venus Earth
and Mars
and we have the four gas giants and then
there was Pluto that looked like a
complete misfit as David said from the
30s when it was discovered until
somewhere in the mid 90s when a second
and then a third and then six and then
10 and now there are a dozen of these
and that not only was Pluto getting more
interesting all of a sudden it became
the archetype of a whole new class of
planet in our solar system that we
didn't realize it was there these little
miniature planets the size of continents
the size of a continent right okay so
this is also very fascinating to think
about trying to launch a satellite nine
years in distance and travel to
hopefully it flies by Pluto close enough
to image it well enough right seems very
difficult it's like mathematically
shooting skeet because you have to lead
it cuz you're not aiming for where it is
now yeah you're aiming for where it's
gonna be in nine years so that you meet
right yeah and you have to get after
that nine year journey of three billion
miles you have to you know hit this
little target in space within nine
minutes of when the desired time or you
miss you know you're pointing in the
wrong direction so after nine years you
have to get there within nine minutes
and they actually came a lot closer than
that it's the navigation and the
precision is just a test David not David
and I flew into San Francisco yesterday
from Houston and the airliner couldn't
get within nine minutes of on time after
only four hours yeah yeah that's
precision yes
so basically traveled a million miles a
day for three thousand days to do that
24/7 seven days a week 52 weeks a year
and with these with the speed changing
also because the gravitational system
Jupiter well well for one thing you're
going uphill against the Sun's gravity
so Suns tugging at you
so you're slowing down and then you pass
Jupiter and you get a boost and then
you're slowing down again but overall
Jupiter gave us this great advantage the
rocket would without Jupiter were taking
us almost 14 years to cross the solar
system with the Jupiter gravity
assistant only took nine and a half so
that was a big help and by the way that
was the New Horizons was the fastest
spacecraft ever launched from Earth it
was a huge rocket an Atlas 5 fully
loaded with extra solid rocket boosters
and tricked out to the max and a tiny
spacecraft mounted on the top of it you
know lightweight spacecraft massive
rocket goes really fast which is what
you need to get there and only nine and
a half years with the Jupiter so let's
give people a feel for the speed yeah so
everybody knows that Apollo was the
lunar exploration program that there
were Apollo missions that we got to the
moon and people may not know but they
launched it 25,000 miles an hour that's
fast and it would take three days to get
the quarter million miles to the moon
New Horizons went from Florida to the
moon in nine hours not three days nine
hours which if you do the math it's
about 0.3 days about ten times faster
and at one point it was pulling 14 G's
acceleration so you wouldn't have wanted
to have a astronauts yes a very strong
little spacecraft now on the spacecraft
itself there's an only a limited amount
of fuel that you can bring right one
fuel tank one fuel tank right and in
order to lower than about 200 pounds of
fuel and that's not used to speed us on
the way the rocket and Jupiter do that
and then we Coast all the way across the
solar system the fuel that's onboard is
used for two purposes one to make tiny
course corrections you know that mount
up over time and allow us to hit that
window in space and that window and time
that David was telling you about okay so
that's to fine tune your trajectory the
other thing is every time we want to
point the cameras of the spectrometer
the instruments on board we fire little
Jets that turn the spacecraft to point
this way or that way and the actual
satellites about the size of it's about
the size of a grand piano a baby granny
animal yeah anyways it weighs about a
thousand pounds so it's tiny you know
the closest comparison is the Voyager
spacecraft which was the previous first
flyby mission to the outer solar system
and New Horizons is dwarfed by Voyager
you know yeah we have a section about
that in the book we were making
comparisons and that section of the book
is called houseboats and hamsters
meaning Voyager and New Horizons okay
this is this is let's go through this
process because having been closer now
with like the kepler team and nasa ames
being right here and has been so
enriching to better understand the sheer
amount of complexity and work that goes
into being able to make this happen a
lot of people have even started telling
me that they only get to do one mission
per lifetime even and that's that's
mind-blowing it's like why can't we do
more missions for a lifetime
but a lot of people do get to work on a
lot of mission couple missions a
lifetime well no even I mean I've been
on 29 yeah so and I know lots of people
that have been on many but from 89 when
you first yeah start working on the new
horizons right that's when the these
pieces of the consequence conceiving the
mission you have to put together a
proposal that is valid enough to get
funding yeah and then you have to go
through the process of building it it's
actually in this case the first stage
was convincing the system that this had
higher priority than other things
there's only a certain amount of money
and there are lots of hands up with
ideas right so you got to make it into
the funded list then after you do that
then nASA has a competition to see who's
going to build it and fly it we take a
moment to talk
all the other brilliant hands that are
going up and yeah yeah yeah yeah it's so
many people right there are usually many
dozens of ideas there are a lot of our
really worthy it gets it goals for
exploration and the budget is such that
you know a mission of this size you get
one or two per decade you know really
and there are people that want to like
go to Venus mission Venus that's one of
my favorite missions there are people
that want to send more missions to
asteroids and comets there people that
want to go back to some of the gas
giants with more missions there and you
know and Pluto was competing against a
lot of worthy goals so just get it
before there was the competition for who
got to build the Pluto mission there was
the can we get this to rise to the top
yeah and so a lot of that is rallying
our colleagues you know you have to
convince your own community the
planetary scientists to take this
seriously and and rank it above other
missions and that's that's hard because
it's a yes and and this is important
because Pluto so far away and takes a
long time to get to it's at a
disadvantage because humans would
naturally if you think about it who
likes delayed gratification right you
can get to Mars in six months Pluto
takes a decade right and so I remember
in the 90s being a young scientist going
in front of senior people and arguing
you should be doing this and I remember
the chairman of one of NASA's most
important committees saying what do you
mean 2015 everyone will be dead by this
and actually there's a story in this
book though about I mean part of that
long time scale there's this sort of
intergenerational commitment commitment
to the future when you commit to this
and there are a lot of people that are
involved that know they may not live to
see that call so it's almost like you're
building a cathedral or something you're
in it because of the goal and there's a
story in this there was one of the times
when New Horizons when a Muto mission
before it was even New Horizons was on
the line and there's the there was a
senior scientist named Don Hutton who
was like a God in our field and he got
up at one of these meetings one of these
committee meetings when NASA was
battling Pluto versus other mission
and there were people saying oh this is
too far in the future and all these
things you know it's not important and
this guy done huntin who is like this
real intimidating but awesome guy he got
up and said you know god damn it I don't
expect to be alive when this mission
gets to Pluto but this is important
let's get on with it let's do it and
people like committing to saying it
doesn't matter if I get to do it we need
to do it yeah you know that was a part
of it that is such a it's a lot of what
we talked about on the show is designing
civilization for Prosperity for all the
future generations to come
this is not about what I want today this
is about how we can build it so that we
last forever and that we have been
prospering so with this with this notion
of almost self-sacrifice
I want to sacrifice my time my effort my
resources even if I don't get to live
through the fruits others will get to
live through the force basically as an
example of a collective enterprise that
is inherently future oriented and we
need to learn to think more that way so
this is I think this is a good example
of that right and now it's our challenge
of course to pay it forward the same way
right that's right we need to support
people young people doing missions that
we won't live to see but you know I want
them to do it and more funding in
general for all the hands that are going
up and thank goodness for private space
enterprise as well at the same time yeah
now that we can hopefully get a bunch of
different people working on this we can
fund more of these hands that are going
up and actually get everyone's little
pockets of their hospital fills there's
basically three ways to do more
spaceflight you can have more money for
NASA you can do missions within NASA
more efficiently so to fit more in the
budget you have or you can have leverage
from external partners like commercial
spaceflight right and all three it turns
out those are not mutually exclusive we
need all three ways right it's like the
fork the spoon the knife at the table
right take anyone away and you find the
meal harder to accomplish Yeah right
there are different different tools for
different purposes there okay and you
know one thing that's really cool about
the New Horizons mission and we talked
about that this in chasing New Horizons
was
there was a lot of innovation because
they were forced to do things
inexpensively there were several times
when the mission was not going to happen
if it was done by business as usual the
more expensive way that things had been
done so rather than just saying we can't
do this they said we're gonna figure out
clever ways to do it with a smaller more
capable lower cost spacecraft and that
kind of innovation then you know it
worked and it also enables more future
missions to use those innovations and so
these things build on themselves - how
does how does how does the team figure
out what goes into the grand piano well
that's a very detailed engineering
process and then ultimately it's you
know it's it's like playing 20
dimensional chess because it's not just
fit within we're in a certain amount of
mass that we could throw to Pluto with
the big rocket thousand pounds yeah so
you have to fit within the mass and 200
was fuel yeah exactly but but in
addition there's some things you have to
have like you have to have a way to
communicate
all right the center so that's not
optional right but which scientific
instruments you send you know that's
more of your your your choice but we
also had a budget constraint so it had
to be something that could be built
within the budget or we would get
cancelled so the design and the whole
concept of operations of how you do it
so in addition to fitting in mass you
have to fit and budget but then in
addition to that we had a nuclear power
supply because we're flying too far away
to use solar we're using vision we no no
we're just using the radioactive decay
of plutonium the element named after
it's not a nuclear reactor yes it's a
battery the plutonium is the heat source
that drives the like I let an electrical
power source but but then but it only
generates 200 watts three lightbulbs so
then your design has to fit within the
mass and the cost but it also can't use
more than 200 watts ever because you
don't have it okay and then there are
many other constraints as well so it
ends up being rocket science and I mean
can't freeze out there it has to it has
to take care of itself in terms of
temperature and many other things you
it's gonna be very far away from the
earth and even at the speed of light
communicating with it can take hours at
Pluto's nine hours round-trip problem
occurs cuz help for an F hours - you
hear the help yeah somebody throws the
switch in Mission Control instantly four
and a half hours till he gets back
that's too much time so spacecraft had
all this software on it to watch for
problems itself
I didn't take care of it in fact there's
one really dramatic moment when the
almost at Pluto after nine years of
mostly flawless flight a crisis happened
at Pluto's door we almost lost it it was
briefly out of communication completely
and they didn't know if they would get
it back and then when they got it back
it was messed up and they had to quickly
restore all the software that had been
lost that they could not do the flyby of
Pluto without the software yeah and at
that time there's days only days left
and it takes nine hours to do the
round-trip and so the team just like
went into action was like you know you
know Apollo 13 that when they're all
like they're you know sleeping on the
floor and eating all the candy machines
24 around-the-clock and they're all like
putting their heads together and we
gotta solve this it was like that it was
amazing and with the hours to spare yeah
they they got it working again
Wow that became way more dramatic yeah
it was not four hours to spare FD a nine
and a half years how's that you couldn't
have written a movie script it was
better I mean I didn't want that to
happen but when if you think about it
now that it's over and we know it all
worked right now it makes it not already
but you probably would have preferred
not to it's it's a it's a marvelous
plotline yeah right unless you have to
live it yeah it also puts humans to the
test - the test yeah oh yeah right but
just picture the scene imagine this was
a movie right that it's a four year
movie it's the 4th of July 2015 this is
the last day we give people off it's a
Saturday they're like home with their
families we got a skeleton crew in right
and this problem develops the spacecraft
while we're receiving signals also you
goes offline never happened in nine and
a half years of flight okay dead silence
getting phone calls so everybody gets
phone calls if I will start coming in
Allen tree gets activated right of
course every but its fourth of July so
they're like by the pool grill and their
burgers right right so so people start
coming they don't know what they're
coming in for they don't know if they're
coming in it might be for an hour - we
need a meeting something's up
turns out they were there for days on
end yeah and and you you have to picture
this team of like super intelligent
driven flight controllers and engineers
and scientists and managers and
everybody's in flip-flops and shorts
right and tank tops and you're like
saving a space mission on the doorstep
of Pluto three billion miles away and we
look like we just all walked in for
picnics right and for three days nobody
went home it's like this
around-the-clock forget about having a
shower right I mean we started phone
train calling even on like all the the
assistants the Secretary's staff to just
come like make runs to you know fast
food restaurants yeah people did not
leave for three plus days but and the
way they they fixed it what's really
fascinating because they figured out you
know sir these nine-hour blocks of time
because that's the natural that's the
timescale at that point to send a
message and have it come back so I know
it takes nine hours to say
are you okay spacecraft and then you
know nine hours it goes yeah okay I'm
okay what do I do and then you say okay
well change your data rate to a faster
data rate so we could communicate better
and that takes nine hours to go to the
up up to the fast data so then you've
used up a chunk of the time you've got
left so they figured out how many of
these nine hour blocks they had there
were three of them
and and so they you know it was very
complex but they made a plan of
everything had to work they do months
worth of software reconstruction in you
know a couple of days and every line of
code had to be perfect because without
that software the spacecraft would go
flying past Pluto and not take the
pictures yeah and there was no stopping
it it was
barreling in a million miles a day at
that point so it was pretty intense
and they did it they saw they fix it but
there was not a lot of room to not allow
wiggle room this is such an ultimate
story actually with especially with the
amount of work that went into it in the
very last couple of of moments leading
up to it so okay so now maybe we talked
about what we learned from the imaging
what did what did we learn from the
imaging images that were sent back to us
about about Pluto well take a look at
the image behind you all right yeah it's
one a complicated place right like crazy
yeah everywhere you look there's
different stuff going on right it's it's
incredibly beautiful just on an
aesthetic you know it's like who would
have thunk it and then scientifically
it's so rich you see so many different
areas and they each have a different
story to tell this it's a really complex
place to make a pun the heart of the
matter is the heart the heart-shaped
feature on Pluto's surface that you see
there you might want to point it out to
people a heart-shaped feature
yeah that you got one half of that's
right that's the left side and then
there's a matching right side yeah go to
your right yeah yeah over there right
yeah there's another blow yes yes you
know Alan Alan a heart looks like this
you're right it's like exactly it's left
and right right there you go there you
go so the left side the the north's at
the top the North Pole's at the top so
the left side that your point net is a
giant glacier made of nitrogen frozen
nitrogen yes yes now let's get the size
right okay that glacier it's not shaped
like but it's the size if you took Texas
and Oklahoma and combined them Wow
so it's about a million square
kilometers of glacier
it's the largest glacier ever found in
the solar system except on earth Wow on
this little planet Pluto okay Antarctica
yeah yeah and the thing is before New
Horizons okay a lot of people a lot of
scientists expected that it would be
completely covered with craters because
old surfaces
inactive are you've seen a lot of you
know picture the older areas of the moon
or some of the moons are just covered
with craters and no atmosphere to burn
out yeah there's a little has a thin
atmosphere but right no atmosphere to
block craters yeah so to speak up and
and so the expectation was it was going
to be old and you can see there's
certain areas if we look to that to the
west the left of the heart there's some
ancient at red that's the call surface
could have looked like that but this
vast area with not one impact crater
that tells you this is active this is
new this is fresh something's moving and
happening there and that itself was a
huge revelation that on a planet this
size that far from the Sun there could
be that kind of fresh activity fresh
activity yeah right and then we
discovered evidence that inside of Pluto
is a liquid water ocean the that
everyone always every about Titan
everywhere so so yeah all the way at the
far edge of the solar system are usually
talking about the moons of Saturn and
Jupiter it's right and because there's
liquid water they go oh astrobiology
there could be what you know could be
life well puto now has to be added to
that list because there's pretty good
evidence that there's probably there's
more water in that ocean of Pluto than
there are in all the oceans on the
surface the earth Wow Wow
yeah because the question is are there
more fish yeah yeah exactly what are the
forms of life yeah if there are we're
we're everywhere it's a global ocean
it's underneath underneath underneath
and how did we disco how do we uncover
that okay so before the flyby you can
make models in a computer of the
temperature and pressure as a function
of depth inside the planet and you you
could predict that at a depth of several
hundred kilometers below the surface the
temperature was warm enough to for the
ice the liquid water ice to melt and
become liquid all right so I said that
wrong but the frozen water ice to melt
and become liquid it does pluto have a
hot core it's warm but not not molten
like the earth but there are heat
sources there is a heat source well a
two heat source remember that
putos not all ice there's a lot of rock
and rock there's radioactive elements in
it that are messing and making heat
right and that's one source of that heat
okay so we had reason to suspect that
there could be an ocean inside so the
the first step in in in what New
Horizons taught us is is that we found
from the topography and from our
spectroscopy which is the technique that
your fingerprint compositions that the
crust of Pluto is made of water ice okay
okay so before that was the hypothesis
it never been spotted from Earth from
Pluto from New Horizons we got that so
now we know that that that the stuff
that will melt at depth is actually
there if it had made entirely of rock or
some or many other things it would be
game over for a liquid water ocean so
first of all the raw materials there but
then we found that that feature the
heart okay
is exactly opposite 180 degrees exactly
from Pluto's big moon and that's not an
accident that is a what's called an
equilibrium configuration huh and but
the only way to get it there is wherever
the heart formed it had to slide into
position to where it's now stable the
moon did no huh the heart did in order
to slide the planet's orientation the
crust had to slide around yes but the
crust can only do that if it's
lubricated from below so that it can
mmm-hmm it can do that so that's the
evidence Pluto has five moons
one giant one called Sharon I mean giant
relative to the size of Pluto big and
round
if it was on its own orbiting the Sun
you'd say it's a small planet okay and
then there are four little ones that so
there's Pluto and its moon and then
there are four little ones that circle
the pair got it so now so now you know
the gravitational pull from Sharon yeah
he's causing a cause and then the heart
was the equilibrium of the balance on
the other end and so then the liquidus
surface
though sorry though the subsurface
subsurface was able to shape move the
heart to a place of exact overtime right
so that's the circumstantial evidence so
it's like the sits fits the picture of a
liquid water like the CSI story right
right right
right we have we have strong
circumstantial evidence and we can't
think of a simpler way to explain this
yeah what we need to do is go back with
an orbiter that really sounds below the
ice with radar techniques and magnetics
and other other scientific techniques to
to prove and detect that water ice
instead of robots and then we need to go
down there in and check out the fishies
and then send those back yeah yeah then
there's a whole and maybe you know you
see down at the bottom to where that you
could see the topography a little more
because of the shadows there's some high
mountains there my mountains all around
but some of them are harder to see in
this projection but those mountains are
made out of water ice that's the bedrock
there it's so cold there that water ice
has the strength basically of rock on
earth and those mountains are the size
of the Rocky Mountains
I mean you know they're just a billion
feet high and huge and they're they're
made out of water and some of them have
snow caps of methane Oh methane yeah
it's pretty well it's like all the same
stuff you have on earth
glaciers mountains snow caps but on
earth the glaciers water or mountains or
rock and the snow caps are water here
and glaciers are solid nitrogen the
stuff that we're breathing right now the
mountains are water ice and the snow
caps are methane natural gas so he's
like all the same stuff made out of
completely different materials because
the temperature is so different right
but we also found giant rift valleys we
found parts of Pluto that the surface is
not changed in four billion years we
found okay what looks like a frozen lake
in a mountain valley it's about 30 miles
long we found volcanoes the size of
Mauna Lowa
all this is going on on one little
planet yes nice [ __ ] do you point
back where you were pointing just before
just below right there where you're
pointing Yeah right
go one inch to the left you see that
hole in the ground yeah yeah that is a
mound all around it
it's about 15,000 fair eye the hole is
called the caldera
that's the tube that goes down to
wherever the magma chamber is that
feature is the size of a big volcano on
Hawaii
except it doesn't emit magma it emits
ices they shoot out its ice yes yeah
yeah that's so cool yeah it's a sci-fi
planet and the sci-fi planet yes totally
and that you're you're the composition
nitrogen glacier Yeah right and then ice
water ice mountain and the methane top
yeah methane snow caps nothing snow cap
yeah wow this is just this is a crazy
place that's this is it's like when you
when you're when we're first uncovering
the the methane oceans on Titan and then
yeah the geysers on Enceladus and
wanting to do the flyby to capture some
of it right there's all these amazing
missions that have to happen and I'm
curious as to how do we how do we you
you were giving these sources for the
ways that we can potentially get
decrease the cost of the missions
increase the funding for private eyes as
well
it's like and there's you know the the
book about you know Astrophysical people
in a hurry for with Neil and you know
your book the earth in human hands these
books have slowly been inspiring more
people to look up go get out of the
light pollution be like what it would
exists out there how can we get inspired
by the cosmos the all these stories that
you know so the Shaw stack and I have
talked about when you're looking a kid
when they're six or eight or ten years
old looks at the rings of Saturn through
a telescope and it's game over then
they're they're sold on the beauty of
the cosmos forever
how how do we get to getting all these
missions to happen and like think about
the expansion of the minds of all the
young kids and where they'll lead us to
well you know I think that these things
to feed on themselves I mean Alan and I
when we were kids we watched Apollo and
watch the first five us to you know Mars
and Jupiter and Saturn and we were like
they want to do
or that you know now kids are watching
New Horizons and it's like their Apollo
people have taught us that yeah you know
and hopefully I'm chasing new horizons
we've told the story in a way that will
inspire people and shown you know sort
of how it works and how you can solve
there's a lot of problems to solve some
of them are human and political some
other were technical but you know where
there's a will there's a way and and you
know Allen and his colleagues they
decided they wanted to do this and they
found a way to do it and I think that
kids young people will be inspired to
realize that you know it's in pop it's
possible to achieve things that people
are telling you may not be possible if
you if you just get determined and stick
to it you know that's definitely one of
the lessons here yeah yeah you know that
story repeats itself you know Columbus
was told he don't sail west you'll fall
off the edge you know that there's
there's nothing over there you know and
the Wright brothers were told you know
you'll never mastered you can't do
flight you know that's for balloons and
gliders but there's no such thing as
powered flight right and in the 40s they
were saying that Rockets wouldn't work
in space because there's nothing to push
against in the vacuum right and human
beings are just amazing you know we're
inquisitive and we're in a chirally
explorers and we're very ingenious as a
species and we make we make stuff happen
and this is really a story about
teamwork too I mean in an individual
human cannot do something like this
Allen talks about that you know
spaceflight is not something one person
can achieve it's a team sport and this
story of New Horizons a test testament
to that you know at one point there were
2,500 people working on the project
including you know building the rocket
and everything and then it was a much
smaller team that was involved you know
like 50 people that were flying it
across the solar system but it's a team
you know and this is about what human
beings can do when they get together and
organize themselves and and focus on a
long-term goal that that's important to
them you know yeah
I love we talked about this so much on
the show that the expanding the minds of
youth to these new dimensions of thought
and getting them really like you said
there's all these different new-age
things that are happening Rockets are
now landing the first stage is now
landing and it's like wow so we're
really making all things we're talking
about but it you could imagine this as
science fiction that we're telling you a
made-up story that's a fictional story
of people that had an idea of doing the
farthest exploration of history and they
battle begins
this and that and they you know they got
knocked down and they came back and I
got knocked down and they came back and
then then okay now there's gonna be this
mission to this faraway place and then
they get put in position of having to
compete for it and it's like David
versus Goliath
but somehow David wins and then they get
into it but they have to do it quick and
low-budget and there's all these
problems but they get it through the
launch pad and then they launch it and
it works and then has to fly three
billion miles and right on Pluto's
doorstep
it nearly you know goes buzz dead it
nearly buys it right but they save it
with four hours to go and then they
discover the sci-fi planet and all of
its moves that sounds like a novel yes
right except that book is nonfiction yes
and every story in there is something
that actually happened yeah right it's
amazing how when I started on this with
some other people and you know at the
beginning we would never believed any
given chapter in that book I usually
think it's good that Allan and his
colleagues did not know what they are
getting in for they were pretty young
they knew that they wanted to do it but
they didn't really know how the system
work and part of what's cool about
chasing new horizons is that in the
story they figure out how it works
and so the reader figures out how it
works along with them and so there's a
lot that reveals you know how
spaceflight actually happens from the
dream to the reality but I think it's
really good that they didn't couldn't
see the whole road ahead of him I don't
know if they I haven't probably would
have stuck with it because he's just you
know like that but everybody would have
you know so it's sort of maybe good that
it was kind of one step at a time and
then they they made it through the maze
it's like they didn't see the whole maze
from the beginning and there were times
when people were just we just we can't
do this anymore
yeah you know we've tried every key to
this lock that we can think of and and
somehow we we never quit and and we just
try it again and we finally figured it
out I really want I know you guys wanted
to be a movie I think people keep
telling us that yeah but they're reading
this and they're like the scene is like
Apollo 13 or this you know I couldn't
believe it's like a movie and were like
oh yeah well that sounds pretty good so
every time my phone rings now I'm
checking to see if the area codes from
Hollywood you know it figure it's only a
matter of time yeah yeah of course the
way that it becomes a movie is it first
it becomes a best-seller people buy it
in large numbers and that creates a
market right so sometimes people don't
even know that they want this yeah
inspiring and so then hopefully there's
a as the media arm of inspiration and
science and education and
entrepreneurship and all these things
that were trying to stir together if
once this gets large enough hopefully we
can even take on bigger projects like
going on to make inspirational films
after books like chasing Horizons yeah
let's do it yeah exactly exactly I
really want to make sure that we
showcase my other vehicle explored
Cluedo is that a cool bumper sticker all
right but but let's let's go in a little
bit more detail on the right is the
mission emblem with the American flag
the people who paid for it and the
little nine sided mission patch says New
Horizons and on the left is an actual
picture of Pluto made by New Horizons in
true color huh
looking back at the blue skies of Pluto
it's in a review mirror because now we
passed Pluto
correct what a review mirrors say on
that fine print objects in the mirror
we're closer than they appear
yes exactly what was the actual distance
between
the spacecraft in them in the planet a
little more than ten thousand miles
thousand my rice which for perspective
of diameter of the earth is eight eight
thousand miles yeah so crossing the
whole solar system and you're about
about an earth away from Pluto and get
this so we have telescopes on board the
cameras look down through telescopes and
if we flew New Horizons at the same
altitude over San Francisco and we're
taking pictures
we'd be spotting individual buildings in
the city with those telescopes yeah so
these are detailed images because we
have magnification from the telescope's
even though you say ten thousand miles
that's like you're taking the picture
from let's say India to the United
States but with telescopes we have these
incredibly detailed images that could
pick out football-field-sized objects
even smaller and this is again what went
into the grand piano the limited amount
of space right have you I put two in the
best seven scientific instruments to do
everything from measure the temperature
of the surface to the composition of the
surface what was the temperature very
low like thirty degrees above absolute
zero
[Laughter]
very cold
I mean that's why you have this bizarre
science fiction world of nitrogen
glaciers and towering ice mountains
because at those ridiculously cold
temperatures these familiar materials
behave in that strange way and then
maybe there's underneath well we know
it's warmer underneath because there's
planets that's what they do they're
hotter and hotter inside and unless
they're really rogue from their star but
you know even still they've war they're
always hotter inside because there's
always some level of heat generation
because the radio and okay and they're
generally formed hot and takes a while
to cool off and just the physics of it
is such that the surface is radiating
space but the inside is insulated by the
rest of the planets or they're always
hotter inside so it's just a question of
is it hot enough at the right pressure
to generate liquid water mm-hmm and
we're pretty sure that in this case
we've seen the evidence that it is so
then there there's some other I mean
I'll just give you some examples I want
to hear more about the
fools as well okay but I would like to
tell you first about it's just a few
examples of things that make this a very
human story I'll give you four and very
rapid fire back in the early 90s the
United States issued a stamp set for the
exploration of the planets had the first
spacecraft of Mercury Mars Venus Jupiter
all those and for Pluto we just said not
yet explored we pasted that stamp on our
spacecraft and flew it in Pluto's face
that's number one number two the guy
that discovered Pluto clyde tombaugh
died at age 91 in 1997 after that he
asked he asked if you guys ever do get a
Pluto mission because we're in the early
stages working on would you find my
ashes we did that we sent his ashes to
his planet Wow okay yeah all right when
we got started on this project we wanted
to engage the public in as many ways as
we could and so we flew a little cd-rom
that was the technology 15 years ago
with an Ames and half a million people
across the country in the world that
wanted to have their names flown all the
way to Pluto yeah right right and then
there's the story right as we're about
to get to Pluto we've been at this for
15 years we're only a couple months out
people in the project starting to say
wait a minute did we have to do this
because I've been looking forward to it
so long I don't know how cope when it's
in my past and I don't have it to look
forward to anymore how's that widespread
sense of trepidation of like what's
gonna happen to me in my life now yeah
when this thing there's been this
organizing principle we're gonna get to
Pluto and you know how many years and
now it's weeks and what am I gonna do
afterwards am I gonna be let down build
have some kind of a cracker like dynamo
yeah build up yeah and the peak
experience and then it's always what can
I do afterward okay look for two after
and during the fire by yourself a lot of
people describe this really surreal
experience of you know time just like
being unreal like I know this is one of
the peak moments of my life and it's all
happening so fast I'm gonna be replaying
this movie forever I better observe
every detail and yet I'm so busy
yeah and I'm so sleep-deprived because a
lot of that too so with the flyby itself
was an intense emotional time so
interesting that time gets warped in
that ahmed's in a different way where
you're observing everything even though
your brain's sleep-deprived you've been
working so difficult you hard on it that
you can retain the moments so that you
can replay them and yeah and you know we
tell some of the stories they're really
inside baseball stories of like what
it's like to really be on space flight
projects so so here's an example just
one so after we launch on this enormous
rocket the size of a downtown building
and the first day spacecrafts on its way
headed out to the moon right there's
this ridiculous party with 500 people at
this hotel on a beach in Florida a few
miles from the launch site and and I get
tapped on the shoulder and you know dr.
stern would you come out here on the
back we want to be something going on in
the beach we want you see I go out there
and they're building a bonfire I don't
know what's that that's cool what's that
all about he said all the malfunction
procedures for the launch everything
might go wrong we're gonna burn it
because it worked we don't need those
anymore so that you have these engineers
you know that you used to think of
engineers you know with Apopka
particular they're like out there with
their mai tais and their beers and
gleefully pulling the pages out of this
thing and throwing it out this bonfire
and the flames are rising into the sky
and everybody's dancing around this
thing and the book is really well
Illustrated there's a picture of that
bonfire is one of dozens of images oh
yeah it's in there yeah you totally
brought us to this human perspective
about all of this and I'm really happy
that you did that I don't think there's
a book like this yet this is a different
different way of telling it what
they're in the early days of the
computer revolution in the eighties a
guy named Tracy Kidder wrote a book
called the soul of a new machine about
it was what it was like to invent one of
the first PCs it was actually a mini
computer then but the idea was like this
is that the revolution of computing has
started this is what it's like to be
inside this this sleepless 24/7 world
that they're trying to build the best
machine ever right and this is kind of
soul of a new machine for spaceflight I
like that he's Tracy Kidder
Oh Jesse Kidder is an amazing writer but
I do think that we tell the story in a
way that hasn't been told before of what
spaceflight is really like and what it
really takes yeah and all of those
different components that went into it
and the human aspect of it and all the
different tools on board to make all the
scientific evidence come back to us to
get inspired by more hopefully in the
future we can take the way that you told
this story and we can take that and it's
kind of the future Stiles will also be
in the somewhat synchronous with this
because you've added so many of the
crucial elements that are usually not
told along the way this is let's look
yes our timer thank you
that's our 15-minute timer okay I'd like
to hear a high-tech approach to
high-tech approach to things yeah
now there's an Earthbound device because
that would not work in zero gravity
nothing would pour out but if you if you
were running it on say Mars would it
work but on a different time scale yeah
what is it same seven seventy percent of
the service I got 30 minutes high Murs
yeah yeah yeah right anyways that's a an
exercise for the student yeah yeah is it
is it 70 or 30% it's 30%
well 35 a Mars happy 30 doesn't gravity
gravitational pulls all right that would
make the timer hour and a half an hour
to have something like that
okay let's see it's quick math okay else
that simply anyways yes yeah couple K so
a couple quick questions that we
typically ask our guests on the show so
as we kind of move forward into a more
globalized era where we're hopefully
collaborating across the world hopefully
we don't need to have an alien
civilization come up for us to figure
out we're all one tribe and that we
should all work together hopefully we
can figure that out before that before
Independence Day so so how how can we
best work together across all of our
across all of our countries to build a
better world for all both in terms of
space as well as economically and
politically yeah well one thing is you
know spaceflight is inherently
cooperatives cooperative as we've been
talking about and there's an aspect of
it that's inherently global I mean
obviously there's competition on all
kinds of levels between different teams
within NASA between now between NASA and
different agencies but there's also
inherent cooperativeness to it I mean
there's something with automation
yeah the space station is a great
example we talk in this book about
something that the amazing thing that
most people don't know about which is
called the Deep Space Network which is
this global network of telescopes
there's three giant dishes one in
calculus
radio telescopes one big big radio
dishes football-field-sized one in
California one in Madrid one in
Australia and you need them distributed
around the planet because wherever a
spacecraft is in the solar system and
whatever time it is on earth and the
earth is spinning around one of those
dishes can always directly communicate
with it and they're all in communication
with each other so that you inherently
you need this global connectivity to do
space exploration so there's an aspect
of it and any astronauts always talk
about when they see the Earth from space
they they identify with the whole thing
so it's not like single-handedly gonna
make us all unite and sing Kumbaya with
the rest of the world but it does remind
us of our planetary nature and it
requires a huge large scale cooperation
to be a you know to work now
a good one there's one in space the
space station and then there's this
these three radio telescopes that were
worked on as a planet to be able to keep
in touch yeah that's good that's good to
know the one else you know and like in
in the future you know we're gonna
people are gonna go to Mars they're
gonna go to lots of other places too you
know and you can arrange that as a
competition where there's a winner and
everybody else apparently a loser
because you know you're not first or you
can arrange it as a cooperation instead
of who's first let's get together and
and build a second planet where humans
can live yeah let's build a society
there let's actually do let's let's
colonize that place and other places for
the betterment of mankind right let's
let's really expand and let's start Star
Trek but that takes a world to there is
this sort of sense if we're gonna start
new societies that we can hit the reset
button yeah and like apply lessons
learned yeah because it's you know it's
starting from scratch yeah so there's
you know who knows the way to unfold but
it allows us to reimagine what what a
human civilization would be since we're
gonna create new ones and new places
where they don't exist pressing that
reset button applying all these lessons
to to the next rock that we colonizes
well one of my favorite parts of the
vision I really love that part of the
second planet okay so that's that that's
a little bit on the globalization side
of things what do you guys think about
the as technology now the the Pinker
argument exists that everybody slowly
coming up over time totally true at the
same time all these different
technologies are slowly starting to
exacerbate wealth inequality there's a
lot of technology that people are now
able to leverage in their favor so what
do you guys think is gonna happen with
with the socio-economic stratification
of the species what are your thoughts
about that that's a tough one we don't
really get into that in chasing horizons
but you know it's funny because we live
it we live in such an interesting time
that we're on the one hand there's
increasing inequality
which is kind of freaky because taken to
an extreme that's you know it's just not
stable and and fair but on the other
hand extreme poverty is drastically on
the decline if you look over the years
human well-being it's hard to argue that
this is not the best time to be a human
being alive in terms of all these
metrics infant mortality extreme poverty
is going away education on the rise so
we're at this weird inflection point
where we've got some problems but the
overall trends you know humanity is
actually doing pretty well you know if
we can just like solve a few things like
switching our energy supply before we do
too much damage to our climate you know
so we've got some challenges but I think
I think we you know we've got to give
ourselves some credit you know also that
like technology has been solving a lot
of problems I mean would you want to
live at a time when the life expectancy
was was 30 or would you want to live now
you know at the same time 30 we could
get a lot more of just food sex stars in
quicker and and then potentially live
another life maybe who knows but or yeah
or since that's not guaranteed maybe it
is better to live on a hundred or two
hundred dollars I'll take the longer
life expectancy rather than the thirty
years of food sex and whatever hoping
for another but at the same time you you
do think with that historical I you do
think wouldn't it have been fun to live
a couple thousand years ago I don't
think so
I really don't you've been watching too
many Russell Crowe movies you mean like
being a gladiator or something like
living in the in wasn't enough time your
children would get sick and die of just
simple diseases yeah there's a lot of
tragedy and loss I'm romanticizing a lot
yeah right I think you are and you know
San Francisco is a pretty nice place to
live in most places you know it we have
air conditioning now right and a roof
over our heads and food that will make
you sick
totally and animals don't attack and you
know thousands of years ago these need
to take these things for granted because
we've grown up with them but we're very
safe and have the prospect of a good
life and a lot of ways that people
didn't use to
absolutely I'm a hundred percent on
board at that I also want to make it
clear though that there were there are
aspects of the past that are just you
know we we had a better sense sensory
acuity for vision no question mal there
frankly yeah I would say on the net you
probably want to live now yeah on the
net yeah right there might be certain
aspects there individually prefer yeah
for many different epochs for example I
think you used to we used to have more
time less yes yeah I think being a
hunter-gatherer would have been really
great when times were good there were
probably days that were wonderful you
lived in a place where food was
bountiful you were with your tribe you
you know when times were good but when
times were bad being a hunter-gatherer
would have really sucked when you were
starving and people were dying and
getting eaten and you know it's much
less predictable yeah okay how about
what are your thoughts about how we deal
with socio-economic stratification well
I'm an optimist at heart and I agree
with David that if you do with look a
nerd would call low-pass filtering and
just look at the big picture over time
it's gotten better and better and better
on average for the average person in so
many respects and that argument behind
it cancels out the importance of talking
about like what we do no not at all okay
we always want to do better than we are
doing now we always want to identify
problems and and go resolve those and
they're always new problems but but I
started by saying I was an optimist and
I really believe that the expansion off
the planet of human beings into all
these other places in this solar system
which is vast is going to open up
amazing opportunities for for everything
that humans are good at and hopefully
for everyone hopefully yeah yeah energy
great resources you know they're
available and you know if you look at
past instances of expansions there are a
lot of nasty and awful things you could
say about the expansion into the
Americas totally but there are also
wonderful things like the invention of
democracy definitely and we might invent
new political systems when we have far
away yeah all posts well you talk about
you know extreme inequality and
is a huge worry obviously and the fact
is there's so much disruption happening
now with new technology and nobody
completely knows where it's going and
they're not going to be the same kind of
jobs I think in the long run there just
aren't going to be jobs for a lot of
people and that will be okay if we
create it we're gonna have to re-examine
our assumptions you know at one point
arthur c clarke who's i think i hear to
all of us he said the goal of the future
is full unemployment so that we can play
so we can play yeah but even one of that
part is important and and any can be
building the futures yeah i'm enjoying
our time yeah right but even at least as
important in my view is besides playing
is to take care of one another
yeah right right right and right now
we're in this transitional time where
people are so busy they have a hard time
for example raising their own children
it's just exhausted you know two people
are working and and imagine a world
where no one has to work and we can just
take care of one another that's that's
an amazing thought and play but your end
play you have to take care of yourself
first I don't mean just at the exclude
right but that we can do that of course
which right now we're we're two chopped
up and yet suplexing know I have we have
to ask this question we asked this one
on the show especially to you two all
right do you think we're alone in the
cosmos
no I don't and then what do you think
the civilizations look like ah I think
that it's really impossible for us to
speculate in a really intelligent way we
were talking we always talk about the
movie 2001 because we loved it and it
was sort of seminal for you know for us
and a lot of space geeks in our
generation and one thing that's
brilliant is that they don't depict the
aliens they tell you they excite your
imagination you know some things about
the aliens but you don't see them
because any way you could depict them
would be restricted to our imagination
and therefore would be sort of cheesy so
I mean I think we can talk about their
properties and you know they would have
had to solve some of the same problems
we have dissolved they be they need
energy sources they
you know need to communicate they they'd
have a lot of the same needs but but we
can't say what they look like or in
detail what their civilizations would be
like I mean you know there's a lot of
good science fiction about that because
it's fun to speculate about but you
can't do any better than fiction but you
know and it might be very very different
it might not be we tend to think of our
extrapolations of our own example
absolutely right so we grew up on a
weird planet Earth is completely the
oddball in the solar system and for one
thing it's got oceans on the outside and
so we think of civilizations as being on
the surface of a planet it might be that
they're dominantly inside these
underground oceans that are so common
and they may not even know about one
another because they're insulated by
being on the interior of a planet they
may never develop space first time I've
heard that one oh that's a good one Ron
did you hear that one that's a good one
that because there's so many yeah
there's so much evolution that's
occurred on the inside interior within
the crust subject lands just to be clear
could be civilizations there just to be
clear dr. Alan Stern is not claiming
there's a civilization inside of fluido
who's gonna say who authorized you to
say that that's that's so cool because
they haven't have yet broken that that
is their earth and they don't have the
cosmos they don't they don't even know
the cosmos exists Yeah right
and I mean don't you think they'd figure
it out eventually if they're really
smart and technological and if they're
very common only a small fraction that
they have to figure it out right right
but I'm just saying we tend to be very
limited by our own experience and so
when you flip it and I just gave one
example of something like ocean worlds
just think of her from that perspective
there you go yeah it's even possible
that you know Gerard O'Neill who we also
talked about who was this guy who
invented the notion that people could
live in these big cylindrical space
colonies he used to talk about how the
surface of the planet is really not the
ideal place for developing a
technological civilization where so it's
well he used to say that with some space
in colonies because you could create
your own environment and have new kinds
of societies and other so it may be the
planets are some kind of incubation
incubator phase and then
where it's really at has nothing to do
with planets you can manifest whatever
sort of life you want on massive
spaceships right yeah versus yeah solar
powered traveling the universe yeah
spinning spinning so you have internal
gravity well I said it wherever you want
to set it yeah
it's so cool okay and then how about we
asked you quick about what do you think
is the most beautiful thing in the world
I would say the most beautiful thing in
the world is human love and compassion
for other human beings and I would say a
close second is planetary evolution and
the amazing manifestation of of nature
and unfolding on all the the worlds in
the universe and of course the human
experiences is a part of the
manifestation of one planet so the two
are connected right I would use two I
words inquisitiveness and intimacy
who's the my two nice very much so kind
of piggyback each other yeah yeah yeah
awesome
yes think we're in a computer simulation
no not at all no thinks is base reality
I mean if that idea is intriguing but I
find it sort of useless yes cuz you
can't test it and it's it doesn't have
one to get it maybe but I don't know I
just it's pointless we're here oh right
dude doesn't ring true to me but then
that's the whole argument about freewill
so then that that would take another
time or is it free right can we turn
this back over three or four times okay
yeah three four more times you guys Rock
this has been such a pleasure thank you
they even think so thanks a lot Tim I'm
talking to Ellen thank you so much so
much fun
see see new horizons links in the bio
everyone check it out it's being sold
across Amazon and all the other sellers
across the entire solar system across
the film in independent booksellers even
in directing more sellers yeah so do
check it out and then
dr. funky spoon on Twitter and stern on
Twitter do you find them go follow them
they do tweet about very interesting
things so do go check them out everyone
thanks for tuning in if you guys you
guys had a good time learning about the
complexity of chasing new horizons and
the complexity of actually all this
crazy epicness going on right here and
on all the other cool places in our
solar system and how we can work
together to get there then share this
content with other people let's get more
people talking about it get more of them
inspired to build the future together
give us a subscribe on the channel
comment below with your thoughts we'd
love to hear from you and feature you
across Twitter and Instagram as well and
do join us on patreon we need to support
the studio we need to keep growing this
project and keep bringing in great
guests and continue building out
creative incubators for people to be
able to get and use different production
equipment to communicate their voices
and amplify them so join us on patreon
thanks everyone for tuning in thanks
round Harvick's are producing partner
gave it out such a pleasure hopefully
see you guys again soon thanks Allen
thanks a lot thanks everyone